it was dark when the two trains collided
head on at high speed
we heard a big bang 10 nightmarish
seconds we were turning over in the
wagon until we fell on our sides and
until the commotion stopped there was
Panic cables fire the fire was immediate
as we were turning over we were being
burned fire was right and left
workers are at the accident site and
searching for survivors those who made
it out were still coming to terms with
what happened
people naturally were scared very scared
actually they were looking around
searching they didn't know where they
were
one was a passenger train carrying
around 350 people it departed Athens
around 7 30 in the evening traveling to
Thessaloniki the Collision happened with
a cargo train outside the city of
Larissa in Central Greece and the cause
of the crash remains unclear
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera